so the ceo of redfit then uh in who was
on episode 1261 great guest glenn
clailman has been on this program friend
of the pod he's been on a half dozen
times he is awesome he spoke with the
new york times and warned about the
dangers of pouring money into homes
quote
without having a clear idea of how
you're going to make money on almost
every single home
if that happens he said you're just
putting the housing markets the capital
markets at some degree of risk and this
is the criticism of zillow was like
we're in a housing crisis for some giant
company to start taking homes off the
market same criticism of open door
it was like these eye buyers are are
exacerbating
the housing crunch so i think that might
be a little bit of a two maybe zillow
realizes this is a tough business and
you become hated maybe regulations will
come like the government will intervene
because of it so according to
bloomberg's reporting zillow is looking
to sell about 7 000 homes
to other institutional investors to get
them off their books
uh again
the number of those seven thousand
dollar seven thousand homes is 2.8
billion
zillow's current market cap is 21
billion
that's uh down
50 from their peak valuation of 48
billion in february of 2021. so zillow
has lost half of its value wow
uh in a year
and uh no i'm sorry they've lost half
their value since february of this past
year in six months wow according to
research firm yipit data i've never
heard of that firm zillow put a record
number of homes on the market back in
september but appears they are not being
sold at a profit according to a study of
650 zillow owned homes done by key bank
capital markets two thirds were priced
for less than the company bought them
for
so
zillow is going to take a big write-off
here obviously this is a huge mistake a
blunder
but
what i will say is
uh no risk no reward
so
while it's easy to kick zillow when
they're down here
they took a bold bet what if it paid off
and it's a minor uh charge for a company
that's worth 21 billion to take a 500
million a billion dollar charge
i would rather see a company taking big
bold bets like this than not taking them
you got to take bets in business you got
to keep shooting for growth
and so
zillow did pause buying before all this
back in march 23 and 2020
when the coveted state orders kicked off
they quickly sold off as well so
i think that this is a great learning
experience period end of story and good
on zillow for trying and maybe they just
think their other model
or they have another concept they want
to iterate on
but
you know they bought
houses for 400k and uh
on average if you take the 2.8 billion
and divide it by 7000
that's the mean
not the median so i don't know what the
most common home price is but it looks
like they bought
first-time buyer homes starter homes
which is smart because that's what the
world needs more of but uh it's hard to
do everything and boiling the ocean is
hard i think maybe open door since they
only do one thing uh maybe they'll be
successful at this where zillow
uh had a harder time with it also i
think maybe zillow looked at their
existing business model
and maybe they were pissing off real
estate brokers right maybe this was
creating too much tension of them being
the owner and seller because if they're
the seller
well then they're fighting against other
sellers in the market so let's think
this through in a gamesmanship theory or
game theory which i'm not an expert on
but if you're the
agent representing a home and you are
seller's
agent
you are
selling
to zillow which means when they sell it
because they're flipping it
you don't get the chance to represent
that home again so every time you sell a
home to zillow by definition
you're removing a piece of inventory
where you sell to any i buyer you remove
a piece of inventory that you'll be able
to
represent in the future and many times i
think you've probably seen this a real
estate broker will represent the same
home two or three times i know uh when
we bought our home one of our homes
uh we then um
tried to sell it with one agent it
didn't sell and then we went back to the
agent
uh and said to the agent who sold it to
us hey you sold this home before your
you know the home would you like to sell
it again and so i think that that's a
strategy that would then make
selling agents not want to work with
zillow so then maybe the selling agents
were trying to offload bad inventory to
zillow to sync them
it's kind of like a very clubby thing
these uh real estate brokers i think
everybody knows when you are in the
process of selling a home the brokers in
many cases
are working with each other
some might say colluding others might
say facilitating
it could be just
facilitating uh most of the time and
sometime colluding to try and get the
buyer and seller to just
you know do a transaction by any means
necessary because remember the incentive
is to close any transaction it doesn't
matter
what the price is you just gotta sell it
price doesn't matter right if they sell
a home for if they're six percent if you
sell the home for a million dollars you
make 60. you sell it for 900 or you sell
it you sell it for two for 900 or 1.1
which is a 10 20 swing and prices there
it doesn't really affect their
commission it's still gonna be
plus or minus ten percent of sixty
thousand fifty four to sixty
uh six thousand right so it doesn't
really matter
the commission of 54 to 66 being split
two ways doesn't matter any number in
there is good okay and you know some of
you might know who are listening to the
podcast that every day or
four days a week i record these uh
newscasts live and i just got in a great
question from one of the naughty gang
members
and uh the noted gang member jeff says
jkl do you think i buy is a
fundamentally
unworkable idea or did they not just
execute well i'd say it's the latter i
think
it is
a hard business it's an operational
business to be in and you have to be
relentlessly focused making sure every
single home
is
a tier one top tier home
not a home
uh that is a dog and keith ruboy
uh
had a a note about this
uh just uh recently saying selling or
shorting open door due to zillow's flaws
and is akin to shorting google due to
yahoo's inability to monetize search
well or return long-tail queries
properly
and i think he's probably correct if you
look
yahoo was doing 20 different projects
and search was one of them and google
was doing one project search
and they were just a hundred times
better than or maybe 10 times better
than anybody in the market at that time
maybe they're 20 times better now so
focus matters in startups
and this seems to be
like food delivery
uh or airbnb and operationally intensive
business and in operationally intensive
businesses ones that exist in the real
world you just gotta have a really sharp
blade you cannot be fighting five wars
on five fronts
in this kind of a situation you just
gotta do one thing better than anybody
so i would be long open door
and actually i'd be you know for doing
eye buying and i would be longzillo for
getting back to their original model and
just owning that one so lick your wounds
you get knocked down six times you get
up seven zillow will be fine uh and
that's my way of trying to get the
founder and ceo to come back on the
podcast which probably won't happen
we love you rich come on the pod
everybody do me a favor who's listening
if you know rich tell him to come on the
pod he's got so many great startups that
he's done and he's friends with like 10
of my friends bill gurley everybody
come on the pod not gonna bite
right now linkedin is gonna give you a
hundred dollar credit towards your first
ad campaign all you have to do is go to
linkedin.com this week in startups one
word no spaces no dashes we all know why
you want that hyundai because you need
high quality leads for your startup for
your business every startup founder
every marketer has been there before
you're launching some new campaign the
creative's amazing your team is excited
everything is going according to plan
except you got that thought in the back
of your head it's keeping you up at
night how can i be sure that my
acquisition campaign is going to drive
the high impact leads that my sales team
needs they got to hit their targets they
need the leads well with linkedin ads
you don't need to guess because you're
going to be able to advertise on
linkedin where your message reaches
people who are ready to engage in
business linkedin equals business
business equals linkedin business
linkedin same thing in people's minds
with 30 million companies engaging in
over 71 percent of professionals using
linkedin to inform their business
decisions
linkedin can help you bring the growth
at your company to the next level don't
wait to start achieving your brand and
legion goals get one hundred dollars a
hundy in ad credits forge your first
linkedin campaign at linkedin.com this
weekend startups once again that's
linkedin.com this week in startups for
the hundy terms and conditions of course
apply